welcome to this video playing Solomon
shall I probably screwing this up the
every I don't really speak any French so
this is something that is too difficult
for me I never played them so if we are
black no se5 they all know that stuff
nowadays okay well this is this is
really nothing much if anything but I
don't really know what else to play in
this line um that Creed III actually I'm
not sure or Queenie to yeah it is about
equal this is what I'm trying to save
this is some very decent line form for
black mm-hmm I think I made some mistake
yeah it looks a bit problematic already
he is 93 m simply 93 I have some somehow
have I have confused and confused to
move order or something Black is some
very much very much okay here hmm b3
bishop deform it's a problem
as a very poor gamer why Jeff I really I
really I made some kind of stupid
mistake here and seems and this this
cave like a very decent position the
only thing in my favor is it still
fairly solid it's not like you can just
quickly quickly window or something okay
yeah that's not great but I don't really
know what else to do ideas rupee 1 i'd
be three I didn't want to allow bishops
III for this night that I cannot get rid
of yeah maybe maybe it's still okay all
wasted that sector really active stuff
okay now i'm not sure about that move it
might be good might also be a little bit
too much really
you
hmm yeah I don't know is this really
good this kind of setup here looks it
looks a bit a bit of artificial I can
give this check now for Bishop f4 and
Roxy 100 is there some some sort of
tactic to really use to really take and
make use of that Bishop a 3 is also not
sure it also makes lots of sense I rock
savonius before actually so that's not
really helping me that much I can play
that down
92 now is it's interesting you're
threatening 94
hmm I don't know if this is really any
good takes pawn takes and Joe it's not
working ok this is this is good i have
to do this anyway so what now king d 3
even as good hey this is the right way
blocking this thing and then trying to
get in g 3f for Roxy one also is a move
that is threatened now that looks good
for what that looks good for what maybe
King f4 is a move King f/4g three
g3 and not snap probably not a rock c5
is it's quite nice though
yeah whoopsie to work c5 booksy to still
have Roxy 52 can go to g3 so probably I
should just play the actor nothin really
time morning hmm check you should see
one trying to pin get the Jeep on as
well yeah this move I was afraid of a
little bit this is okay right
check yeah I play I want to play it as
simple as possible not sure it's the
best continuation okay check
yeah just a couple of porns up now check
check check
27 seconds the only thing is you know
the noid said nights are tricky check
check okay the e porn must try I must
try for people
yeah sure position wins but check check
yeah as mentioned as simple as possible
promoting now
check check check check check check
check me okie dokie Wow who tough stuff
always tricky with no time on the clock
yeah I mean I was really coming back
from a from a really poor position where
like it's just controlling business I
don't know what I did wrong I mean the
this line is quite annoying anyway for
white but this was really meant to be
just just play it totally safe you know
what I forgot I have to play Bishop f4
of course yeah of course this is what I
need to do I mean okay it's equal I know
but still I have to play Bishop f4 okay
this is stupid now I mean you always
could play 93 by the way with a good
position but what he did is of course
fine this I'm not sure about but he
always keeps them a pretty substantial
advantage but I don't know around yet it
gets to the point where i'm close to
equalising i believe and this is this is
I don't know f5 maybe yeah slowly
gaining a little bit of ground but it's
not nothing nothing to grade but here
problematic night ext4 is a threat and
here it really is is an image is an
issue I rook see one was interesting but
ok computer approves basically what I am
and what I'm doing and now it says h4
with a clean win yeah probably the thing
is that when
these pawns are very very weak and I
will win them what I have to make sure
is that he does not get any counter play
with the king and some kind of some kind
of past porn this is what I was trying
to achieve in the game when I when I
went with this yeah yeah auntie f4 was
strong I am yeah but ok I 40 seconds so
i have to have to be quick and yeah
maybe I made some kind of mistake later
as possible but i only had 30 second are
pretty satisfied with the way I finally
won this thing ok thanks for watching